Суд 28 січня залишив Олексія Навального під вартою, і таким чином головну причину масових протестів у Росії не усунено.
Опозиціонера засудили на 30 діб ув'язнення за порушення підписки про невиїзд у зв'язку зі справою про розкрадання коштів.
Підписку було порушено, оскільки після отруєння "Новачком" опозиціонера перевезли до Німеччини для надання йому там медичної допомоги.
Водночас у ЗМІ з'явилися повідомлення, що Навальному загрожує, у сукупності різних справ, позбавлення волі на понад 13 років.
Напередодні у квартирах Олексія Навального, його близьких та соратників провели обшуки.
Вилучили техніку й у редакції Youtube-каналу "Навальний лайв", на якому кілька днів тому відбулася трансляція фільму "Палац для Володимира Путіна".
Декого з оточення Навального затримали, зокрема юриста Фонду боротьби з корупцією Любов Соболь,
брата Навального Олега, учасницю гурту Pussy Riot Марію Альохіну.
Їм пред'явлені обвинувачення у порушенні карантину під час мітингів 23 січня в Москві.
Однак політологи вважають, що жорсткі заходи влади можуть мати протилежний ефект.
Можна помітити, як занервувала російська влада. Думаю, її стривожили події у Білорусі. Адже білоруські протести спалахнули неочікувано.
А якщо це сталося там, то може статися й у Росії. У вересні будуть вибори до Держдуми, і це ще один аспект, на який треба зважати.
Тому вживаються, на мій погляд, надмірні заходи для того, аби запобігти участі людей у протестах.
Масштаб акцій на підтримку Навального минулими вихідними здивував багатьох.
Вони прокотилися понад сотнею російських міст.
Однак, на думку австрійського експерта Ґергарда Манґотта, вплив протестів на російську владу не варто переоцінювати.
Від масштабних масових протестів виграє насамперед Олексій Навальний.
Це, поза сумнівом, підвищить рівень його визнання в Росії.
Однак не думаю, що масштабні протести зможуть привести до зміни політичного порядку денного в Росії
чи - у найближчому майбутньому - до повалення Путіна.
Я також не вважаю, що протести якось убережуть Навального від, скоріш за все, багаторічного тюремного ув'язнення.
Європейські політики уважно стежать за розвитком у Росії.
Вони не виключають, що силові дії влади можуть не відлякати, а навпаки - мобілізувати людей в акціях протесту.
Влада нервує, робить нераціональні рішення. Рішення, які повинні показати силу. Навального намагаються покарати за те, що він вижив.
Російська влада власноруч робить усе, аби виліпити з доброго політика нового вождя.
Каталізаторами протестів стало затримання Навального та показ його фільму-розслідування про путінський палац.
Він за тиждень набрав понад 100 мільйонів переглядів.
Але ці мільйони людей швидше за все не готові вийти на вулиці, зауважують експерти.
Більшість росіян до корупції звикли і не вважають її приводом для зміни влади.
Соціально-економічна ситуація у Росії нині також не сприяє протестним настроям, переконаний російський соціолог Лев Гудков.
Я не думаю, що ми стоїмо перед хвилею великих масових протестів.
Ситуація різко відрізняється від Білорусі. У Білорусі значно більшою мірою зберіглася радянська модель диктатури й державної економіки.
У Росії за роки процвітання, 2002-2010, утворився жирок накопичення.
Ілюзії, що стагнаційні явища пандемії є тимчасовими і через якийсь час знову буде зростання, нейтралізують невдоволення.
Аби соціальне роздратування вийшло на поверхню,
воно має бути організованим, мають бути структури, політичні партії та рухи.
Умовно опозиційні партії Росії - ЛДПР, КПРФ та "Справедлива Росія", що мають фракції у Держдумі,
не захищають заарештованого Олексія Навального, а навпаки засуджують,
називаючи "зрадником" та "креатурою" західних спецслужб.
Утім, до масових акцій долучається дедалі більше молоді.
Також їх підтримують відомі аполітичні росіяни, шоумени, музиканти.
Зокрема акторка й ведуча Тетяна Лазарєва, відеоблогер Юрій Дудь, репер NoizeMC, автор трилогії-бестселера "Метро" Дмитро Глуховський.
Не всі з них є прихильниками Навального, але розділяють його критику щодо ситуації в Росії.
Влада вживає величезних зусиль, аби виховати в людей пасивність і створити відчуття безглуздості протесту.
Але весь путінський режим насправді не такий багаточисельний.
У статусі-кво зацікавлені силовий прошарок, який годується за рахунок корупційної ренти,
люди, які мають безпосередній стосунок до путінського оточення, які його не зрадять, тому що всім йому зобов'язані.
І, можливо, бюджетники, які бояться, що під час якогось хаосу вони втратять ті гарантії, які в них є.
Сумарно це може бути кілька сотень тисяч - ну, нехай мільйон людей.
Тому влада всіляко демонструє свою повну відвязність, готовність іти до останнього й безкомпромісність.
Плюс створити в людей враження того, що відповідальність за будь-які антидержавні виступи буде неминуча й страшна.
Соратників Навального притягають до відповідальності за "ковідною" статтею 236 - порушення санітарно-епідеміологічних приписів.
Тим часом штаб Навального анонсував нові масові акції протесту по всій Росії у неділю.
Вони, власне, й продемонструють потенціал цих протестів.